10 Shocking Movie Mistakes That Slipped Into
The Final Film
Like any other line of work, mistakes are
made in the world of movie-making.
However, unlike most other lines of work,
movie-making allows for the rectification
of said mistakes without any harm being done,
thanks to the people behind the movies having
the ability to reshoot and reproduce any scenes
in which mistakes are made.
That being said, some mistakes actually occur
without anyone realising - and that means
they can end up being included in the finished
production.
In this video, we'll take a look at some examples
of that happening.
Here are ten shocking movie mistakes that
slipped into the final film.
Zootopia
2016's Zootopia has quickly cemented itself
as one of the greatest animated movies of
all time - and its box office return of more
than $1 billion is well and truly justified
- but it certainly isn't without its flaws
(mostly in the form of continuity errors).In
fact, it's littered with mistakes, one of
which occurs when the black panther Manchas
turns savage and chases Judy and Nick through
the forest.
Judy clearly drops her walkie talkie and it
falls quite a long way below where she's running.
However, a few moments later, it's inexplicably
reattached to her belt - and we don't believe
she can just call it back to her like Thor
does with Mjolnir!
Deadpool
The awesome Deadpool movie featured Ryan Reynolds
starring as the titular Marvel anti-hero,
who is known for his amazing ability to heal
from almost any injury very quickly - but,
if the movie is to be believed, his costume
has that same ability too!Of course, it doesn't
really, but in Deadpool's epic climactic fight
with Ed Skrein's Ajax, the Merc with a Mouth
gets stabbed in the head.
Not only does his head heal fairly quickly,
but the resulting hole in his mask also miraculously
disappears once the knife is removed from
the wound.
I could really use some clothes like that...
Jurassic Park
Jurassic Park is one of the most iconic movies
ever made.
The 1993 offering brought dinosaurs to life
in a way no movie ever had before it - using
almost entirely practical effects to do so
- and that resulted in some fantastic scenes,
as well as some glaring mistakes.In the scene
in which the velociraptors enter the kitchen
in the visitor's centre, where Lex and Tim
are terrified and hiding, as the first raptor
makes its way through the door, you can clearly
see a member of the animatronics team's hand
reaching out to steady the creature's tail.
Way to spoil the illusion, douchebag!
Avatar
The highest-grossing movie of all time by
quite a large margin, you'd be forgiven for
thinking that 2009's Avatar was the perfect
movie.
It is, in fact, far from it, as it contains
a surprisingly high number of mistakes.
In this instance, the mistake we're referring
to happens when Giovanni Ribisi's Parker Selfridge
- the corporate administrator for the RDA
mining operation in the movie - is practising
his putting in one of the RDA's control rooms.
He has 3 golf balls and is shown putting one
of them - but the other two spontaneously
change from being close to each other, to
then being apart, to then being close to each
other again.
Frozen
Frozen is nothing short of a phenomenon.
The success and popularity of the 2013 movie
is unprecedented and it remains the highest-grossing
animated movie of all time to this day.
But it had some glaring errors in it.
When Anna enters the art gallery singing "For
the First Time in Forever", there's a wide
shot of the room that shows that there are
no seats in there.
However, when she starts jumping in front
of paintings and posing, she leaps off a seat
to do so - a seat that clearly appeared out
of thin air, as it wasn't there just seconds
before.
Titanic
Titanic is the second-highest grossing movie
of all time and is generally perceived as
being a cinematic masterpiece.
The acting was first class, as was the directing
of James Cameron, and the intricate set designs
were unbelievably high in detail, but there
were some major flaws in the movie.
A prime example comes in the form of inconsistencies
in the design of the ship itself.
Take the front of the ship, for example.
The gaps in the railings change sizes, the
deck anchor characteristics change dramatically,
and the very front point of the ship changes
its shape - and that doesn't even come close
to covering all mistakes of that nature.
Star Wars: Episode IV - A New Hope
Back when George Lucas first decided to make
Star Wars, he had absolutely no idea just
how big the movie - and indeed the whole franchise
- would become.
As a result, he probably wasn't quite as careful
as he otherwise would've been when it came
to the movie's minor details.
Consequently, the original 1977 film is littered
with mistakes.
One such mistake occurs when Obi-Wan and Luke
enter the Mos Eisley Spaceport and trick the
Storm Troopers into letting them in by using
the force.
One particular Storm Trooper, who is standing
behind their vehicle, suddenly disappears
in an instant.
He's there in one shot and completely gone
in the next.
Given that we don't believe he possessed magical
powers, that's an error.
The Goonies
Ah The Goonies - so quintessentially 80s and
a throwback to the years when kids could still
be kids.
But enough of all that mushy, sentimental
nostalgic stuff, we're here to point out a
silly mistake that occurred before the movie
had even properly started.During the opening
credits, when we're introduced to Jonathan
Ke Huy Quan's Data, the young inventor is
seen testing out a new gadget.
He fires a sucker at a trash can - which is
full of trash - and is inadvertently dragged
towards it before falling in.
However, when he falls in, it has suddenly
become empty.
Self-emptying trash cans?!
Whatever next?
Despicable Me
One of the finest animated movies to ever
hit cinemas, 2010's Despicable Me contains
a plethora of memorable scenes - one of which
takes place in an amusement park, when Gru
is reluctantly persuaded into going there
by his adoptive daughters.
A mistake occurs in this particular scene
when Gru and the girls ride on a roller coaster.
When Gru gets onto the roller coaster, the
cart he gets in clearly has a pink safety
bar on it.
However, when he exits the cart after the
ride has come to an end, the safety bar has
completely disappeared.
Unless he tore it off in sheer terror during
the ride, that wasn't meant to be the case.
Captain America: Civil War
The highest-grossing movie of 2016 so far,
even Captain America: Civil War contained
a number of mistakes - and one of them came
courtesy of the usually-so-meticulous Robert
Downey Jr.In the scene in which the Avengers
first speak to the United States Secretary
of State, Thaddeus Ross, Downey Jr's Tony
Stark alternates between wearing a wedding
ring and not wearing a wedding ring.
Downey Jr. is, of course, married in real
life, but Tony Stark isn't married in the
MCU, so this obviously comes courtesy of some
rare absent-mindedness on the part of the
Oscar-nominated actor.
Bad Robert!
Thanks for watching our video about shocking
movie mistakes that slipped into the final
film.
Did you enjoy this video?
Do you know of any other movie mistakes that
were kept in?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.